honorary awards for special achievements  or services to our industry are  determined by vote of the Academy Board  of Governors and this is an historic  milestone in the life of the Academy in  1972 Charlie Chaplin received an  honorary Oscar  I watched the clip many times the  inscription reads to Charles Chaplin for  the incalculable effect he has had in  making motion pictures the art form of  this century this master of cinema you  know one of the fathers of cinema  returned from a 20-year exile in the  United States because of McCarthyism to  accept this award and it's so moving  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  it's so brief yet it's so powerful and  how can you not be moved to tears  watching him receive it thank you for  the honor of invited me here  wonderful sweet people thank you  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]